This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is one of the episodes that we
filmed during the Psi Phi program.
Joe Rogan questions,
everything it is brought to you by Ting Ting is a cell phone company that gives
you cell phone service that makes sense for you.
They allow you to cancel it anytime.
They don't have contracts,
they use the sprint backbone.
So you're getting dependable,
reliable,
excellent cell phone service,
but you're getting it in a way that you probably wouldn't get from a big
company.
Like for instance,
if you don't use all of your minutes,
if you use less minutes than you thought you would,
ting will actually knock you down to the lower level and then credit you the
difference on your next bill.
That shit is unheard of.
No company does that and I think that's an awesome way to do business.
They're not trying to rob you,
they're just trying to sell you something that's really good and it's an
excellent exchange.
And even exchange,
you give them money,
they give you good cell phone service at a reasonable price.
Um,
ting has on their website a lot of examples that people have sent to them about
how much money they have saved by using ting.
But I can tell you personally,
I have spoken to many people on Twitter and social media that have sent me a
thank you saying that ting saved them a ton of money and it gave them excellent
service with really high end cell phone devices.
They use the android phones and they have all sorts of other different kinds of
phones as well.
But the high end android phones like the Samsung Galaxy s four,
the HTC one,
all the really top end nice devices that you can get a,
I recently just got uh,
one of these,
a galaxy note threes is a fucking ridiculous phone.
It might be too big.
I don't know if I'm going to keep it,
but right now I got it and I am very impressed with the android operating
system.
I haven't fucked with this in a long time.
I got one a long time ago,
like maybe three years ago or something like that.
And it was like a drunk iPhone.
It was such a hunk of shit.
But boy,
have they caught up in a big way.
And this screen is magical.
Anyway,
I'm waxing poetically about learn my new phone.
What I'm telling you is that Ting will save you money,
give you awesome cell phone coverage and make you feel good that you're
connected to a reliable but,
but ethical company that's not trying to fucking rip you off.
So go to [inaudible] dot ting.com and save yourself $25 either off service or
device.
It's your choice.
And,
uh,
enjoy.
And I guarantee you,
if you're looking for some cheaper,
but yet excellent cell phone service,
it doesn't make you feel like you're getting fucked over to.
Here's the way to go.
That's the new song.
To use the word Tuco rogan.tang.com go get your freak on a before this podcast
airs.
I just want to say thank you to the fine folks at Psi Phi and Arthur Smith,
the production company that made my,
my show Joe Rogan questions everything.
Thank you to Tim and Wayne from Scifi also for allowing us to put this on the
air.
Um,
as a podcast,
one of the things that we did when we were filming the show is we wanted to
incorporate the podcast into the show because first of all,
it's the best method that I know of for discussing an issue.
There's one,
one of the things that I found about the show that was kind of awkward.
I really enjoyed doing the show.
I really enjoyed the opportunity to explore all these different topics.
It didn't come out perfect.
There's a lot of things that I want wasn't happy with,
but that's all just a part of the growing pains of creating a show.
Um,
but one thing that I did find is that having conversations in front of people
standing up and weird circumstances like in a hallway or you know,
in a laboratory or whatever,
the many,
many different scenarios that we,
uh,
had conversations on the show is very awkward.
The best way to have a conversation is on a podcast sitting down across each
other in a comfortable chair,
in front of a big oak desk where you're relaxed,
you feel confident,
you're comfortable,
rather you feel comfortable,
you feel it's quiet.
The room is,
you know,
it's,
it's a,
it's a fun place to be.
It feels good.
There's,
there's good energy here and we control that for the most part by having a,
in a podcast form and my favorite aspects of the show,
we're actually Dunkin and myself talking to these people on the podcast and it
was kind of a revelation and a lot of ways it's like,
my favorite part of doing this show is the stuff that I was already doing before
I was doing the show.
But I want to thank thanks Phi for allowing us to do it that way because it
really,
uh,
it came out great.
Um,
those parts of it.
And so now you're going to get the full unedited podcast.
This first one is,
uh,
from the big foot episode and it's Doctor Jeffery Mel,
Mel Drum.
Dr Jeff Meldrum is,
in my opinion,
the most credible of all the big foot believers.
I shouldn't say the most credible because maybe there's some out there.
They're just as credible that I haven't met.
He's the most reasonable guy that I communicated with.
And a,
I really respect him for his,
first of all was,
is stepping out and saying that he really thinks this is a big real undiscovered
primate living in the Pacific northwest,
which takes a lot of balls for someone who's a legit professor.
Uh,
you know,
cause people amazingly think you're fucking crazy if you tell them there's an
unknown monkey living in the woods.
He doesn't just do that.
He does that from an academic point of view.
He's very,
very bright guy.
And he also does that as an expert in human movement.
And I found his theories on the Sasquatch,
uh,
combined with this knowledge that he has about human movement to be very
fascinating and his analysis of footprints and what,
what's unique about these footprints and why it mimics actual real PR,
real primates and not human beings.
In fact,
uh,
I thought it was also incredibly fascinating.
He's a brilliant guy and a very nice guy and I appreciate very much that,
uh,
he took the time out of his busy schedule to come on the show.
So enjoy.
This is doctor Jeff Meldrum and once again,
thanks to everybody involved in the show,
everybody from the cameraman on down,
it was a amazing,
cool place to work for a few months.
So a big kiss.
See you all and now enjoy a podcast with powerful Duncan Trussell n Dr Jeffrey
Meldrum.
[inaudible] tell me when we're ready.
Dr Meldrum.
First of all,
thank you very much for coming here and talking to us about all things squatch.
Don't give an I or a very excited about this.
How many years,
first of all,
have you been involved in this?
Were you in that Leonard Nimoy in search of bigfoot show?
No.
That predated.
Predated,
yeah.
Okay.
That's the Oji of bigfoot shows,
right?
Yeah.
I remember seeing that when I was a kid and being so convinced and excited that
there was a big hairy man living in the woods,
obviously back then I didn't realize that it could be a species.
It wasn't just like one individual dude,
but a whole species.
And I've been fascinated by it since I was a little child.
I don't know why.
I don't know what it is.
What is it about big foot?
Maybe you could tell us,
what is it about big foot that speaks to man?
I there,
there are different levels.
I mean there's the,
just simply the mystery,
something that's undiscovered unresolved.
Uh,
I think there's an added mystique because it's so human.
Like,
I mean,
that's been a,
an icon and an archetype of the human experience since the beginning of history.
Some of the earliest heroes hung out with Wildman,
whether it was a Beowulf Grendel or,
um,
Gilgamesh and Inca.
Do you know,
there,
there were these denisons of the forest that maybe represented are,
are sort of lost connection to wilderness into wild places.
Do you think there's a certain amount of arrogance and assuming that we have a
full detail of the entire fossil record of primates,
when you know,
you see things like Homo Floresiensis,
the Hobbit,
man Dinetia and the evidence of gigantic [inaudible],
which is only,
you know,
the 1920s,
they found that,
right?
Yeah.
This is,
this is a theme that it really is placing Sasquatch in a,
in a very different context.
And one that I keep pushing because I can see this unfolding,
uh,
with every new discovery of,
of a hominid like Homo Floresiensis,
uh,
the,
the tree of,
of Hominid radiation gets bushier and Bush here.
And then discovery after discovery shows that some of these lineages have
persisted to much more recent times in the past than has ever been acknowledged
previously.
So,
you know,
homofloresiensis 13,000 years old,
a new,
a neanderthal site,
maybe 10,000 years old.
Really?
Yeah.
And so the,
the notion that we're the only hominid on the planet,
contrary to all experience in the past,
when there were multiple hominids coexisting on the landscape,
uh,
may be a real misnomer,
real misrepresentation of fact.
And these relic humanoids may be the rule rather than the exception.
It's,
it's a real tricky subject.
The bigfoot Sasquatch subject.
I have brought it up with people that I love and respect and they have mocked me
right in front of my face.
Join the club.
Dana,
Dana White.
Dana White mocked me the other night at dinner right in front of my face and big
guy.
I tell you,
I was pretty disappointed when I heard you were going looking for bigfoot while
I was like,
how dare you sir.
What do you know about big foot man?
It's one of those things.
Yeah,
big foot is like ghosts or flying saucers or crop circles in lumps.
You in a Weirdo category.
It does.
But that's because there is a lot of Weirdos that believe in big foot.
That's right.
You guys know that you probably experienced more lunatics then psychiatry is
due.
And that's what,
uh,
that's what,
Warren's off a lot of my colleagues is they don't want to navigate,
try to navigate that morass of,
of the lunatic fringe.
And so you don't have the luxury of just simply going out and collecting data.
You have to win through all this chaff to find,
find the colonel.
It's very,
I'm sorry,
it's very,
it's like when they lump you in like it's a stain.
It really is a stain on your career and credentials.
They can say,
oh,
he's that big foot guy.
Absolutely.
Well,
there was a moment as I was sitting here contemplating these footprints that
sort of pulled me into this subject when I,
I was familiar with Grover Krantz,
I knew the grief that he'd suffered at the hands of his colleagues because of
his pursuit of this subject,
you know,
in his career,
stalling his career.
And I contemplate for a moment,
do I really want to go down that road or not?
But how could you not when you have 35,
45 fresh footprints laid out in front of you that are so clear,
so compelling,
so persuasive.
I mean,
for me that's what science is about.
It's going after those.
Interesting.
Even if are anomalous,
uh,
data points.
What was it that got you started on this?
Well it was that,
I mean,
I,
you could,
we could go clear back to my childhood when I was born in and a,
in the Pacific northwest and knew of bigfoot,
knew of Roger Patterson and his film.
He came to Spokane where I lived as a,
as a youngster and showed his documentary showcasing that,
that film clip.
But my academic interest began in 1996 when I was shown a very,
see this,
the same line of tracks I just referred to in the blue mountains outside of
Walla Walla.
And,
uh,
I tell you that the hook was set.
Is there ever been a moment we stepped back and said,
hang on,
am I wasting my time
on some hooey?
Sure.
Oh,
sure.
Is there a button,
a lot of hooey involved in the subject?
Because there is,
yeah,
you got to get past that.
But I tell ya what,
I have seen what I've experienced firsthand,
uh,
be it too,
you know,
finding tracks in very remote areas myself,
hearing vocalizations,
having rocks thrown at me.
And what have you,
will tell us about your experiences that you've seen tracks where there's no
people like deep in the woods.
Yeah.
What'd you say?
On several occasions?
Well,
one,
one was in connection with a kind of an interesting it possible interaction.
We never actually saw something or anything,
but,
uh,
when you eliminate,
you know,
when you eliminate the,
the,
uh,
likely,
scenarios,
then the unlikely is what you're left with.
And in this case we had,
we were in the Siskiyou wilderness of northern California,
one of the first expeditions of sorts that I participated in it.
We'd gone off from our base camp quite some distance off trail to investigate
some lakes we thought might've been shrunken up in the,
in the,
uh,
in the heat and exposing mudflats for more tracking opportunities.
We did find a set of tracks in a,
on a dusty stretch of the trail.
You,
you know,
if you've ever been out to camping,
you get up early,
early in the,
and the,
the dust of a camp site is still moistened with the do when you step out of your
tent and everything sticks to your foot.
Those were the kind of footprints that we found on the trail.
One morning.
They were just as clear as it could be something with let's 16 inch foot,
five toes had stepped in that,
uh,
that do laden dust and it just lifted up a perfect to outline of a footprint now
as a big foot freak.
Yeah.
What was that like for you?
This is like your first piece of evidence.
You're stumbling upon it yourself.
That's right.
Yeah.
Well,
it was freaking out.
No,
no.
I mean it was,
it was confirming.
Yeah,
me too well at that,
but by that time,
yeah,
there were moments we'd been in the woods already for over four weeks and so we
had kind of gotten to the point,
uh,
you know,
you have to sort of steel yourself against that natural fear reaction to those
circumstances.
Right.
I think this is something that a lot of big foot hunters assume,
which is that big foot is sweet or big foot's this harmless being that's out
there picking flowers and printing his footprints in the do.
This could be a killer.
This thing could be a deadly angry,
tired,
bitter old jungle ape.
Aren't you worried the,
in your quest for bigfoot,
you actually might find him?
Well,
uh,
find one of them to,
you know,
let's make it clear.
There's more than one.
Yeah.
This is not one loan monster Roman.
That's right.
Yeah,
but,
but you're,
but your points we'll take in,
I mean clearly this,
this,
if it exists,
this is a large,
powerful,
potentially dangerous animal.
Yeah.
It should be shown deference,
but I mean,
if they were killers know,
like grizzly bears,
they would have been hunted to extinction just like grizzlies were in the lower
48 for quite a period of time.
There really isn't.
The only stories you hear about,
uh,
antagonistic,
behavior towards humans is usually precipitated when the humans have shot at
them.
They've,
they've started the coral,
but otherwise they seem to be,
you know,
it's just like with,
um,
with gorillas,
gorillas were build by Barnum and Bailey is the most terrifying creature on the
face of the planet.
But now were they cry?
They're considered the gentle giants,
you know,
the,
uh,
the vicar of the endangered a imperiled trucks,
good for us.
Right.
The,
the predatory primary to the ones that the most dangerous,
right.
Like chimpanzees are more dangerous than gorillas because they're predatory.
True.
Yeah.
This apparently what the law is,
what people believe,
at least is that if Sasquatch is a real thing,
it eats animals,
probably eats elk and it probably falls elk migration.
Sure.
Yeah.
So,
so there is always that risk.
I mean,
you know,
anyone who's going out in the woods should,
should use,
do,
do caution.
No,
I mean,
people eat people.
Exactly.
You Paki do you pack heat?
It depends on the surface that it's not,
not for the doctor.
Dooney carries a gun.
How dare you?
He's about to say pack seat.
Oh,
sure.
No,
it wouldn't.
When we're in the car
field,
I mean we're in areas where there,
where there are grizzly bears where there's cougar,
you know,
northern California,
they've got lots of issues with,
uh,
with cougars preying on or attacking people.
Cougars were personal security should be something.
Yeah,
Kuvan.
I know Joe Pepper spray to pepper spray and I'll thick jacket,
just cougars you want,
you want some,
some,
a lot of protection.
I prefer 10 millimeters so that to son and get some Kevlar,
maybe a sword.
Well,
what a predicament you're putting yourself in because let's say you do run into
a tribe of these things and they've,
they're smart enough to know that they can't be discovered.
You've got to decide between not getting ripped to shreds by these big foot or
blasting them into oblivion.
Sure.
Why do you pick?
Well,
that's a good question.
I mean,
it's a,
I hate to speculate too much on a what if scenario.
I don't think that they're in tribal social organizations or,
or that they are that intelligent.
I mean,
I think we're,
we're dealing with,
uh,
you know,
at least,
uh,
a large prime made a large Ayp and at most,
a very,
uh,
early off shoot of the Hominid radiation that,
you know,
has intelligence that's not much higher than that of a chimp or a gorilla.
Um,
I just have no experience to back up anything beyond that.
If I could let you pick a toe,
any tow tow and we hacked that sucker off and then immediately take you to big
foot,
my camera's crew.
Whole deal.
You get to see Sasquatch,
a whole sound squash family.
Yeah.
Do you accept that?
Do you hack off the toe to meet Sasquatch and know for sure.
I could probably get by without a pinky.
Oh my goodness.
You got a bad,
sir.
I know you're ready to chop off toes.
I'll chop off my toe,
throw my pinky end of the time.
You really,
absolutely.
I love my pinkies.
We're not going to do that.
What's it for?
What does it,
what does it do?
What is a painter?
She move around your freak.
I wouldn't barely wiggles to the left.
And when it pushes off and helps you stabilize the Pinky Taupe?
Yes.
Is there for a reason early at Vienna sausage,
it's like this.
Maybe as mine's very active.
It's hard to,
hard to clip that little nail.
Oh my goodness.
You guys are both sick.
How dare you?
It's tempting though.
You would transform human history with this video.
I want my toes,
dude.
Discussion over.
Not shopping,
but it's a little,
it's a valid question because I mean a guy like you who's been studying this for
how many decades now?
Nearly two decades.
Think about all that time and effort
just to see it.
But it's been a great ride.
I mean,
you know,
I've got to see places on this planet and see some of the most beautiful
landscapes and terrains and meet all kinds of interesting people.
So it's been a,
it's been an interesting experience.
Yeah.
As we talked to one,
a Sasquatch hunter,
what he said was that even if he doesn't find tasks,
watch,
she's still camping.
Oh sure.
Join him.
I'll exactly on those.
Tell people,
you know,
cultivating an appreciation for natural history,
enjoying the outdoors.
Because it's like me with fishing,
if I don't catch a fish in the first five minutes,
I'll start to lose interest pretty soon.
And if you're that way,
chances of you catching a fish or having a Sasquatch experience in the first
weekend,
you go out,
it's pretty slim.
So enjoy what you're doing.
You,
you mentioned that these creatures throw rocks.
How big are their oxidate?
Well,
in my experience,
uh,
when we were there in the Siskey use,
we had,
it was about a softball size drunk.
I mean,
if you want it to cold cocked me,
it could have probably,
but I think it was more of a,
I got the impression it was just,
uh,
letting me know that we were close.
And,
uh,
I got the sensation in fact,
that we had stopped to take a break at a spot that was on,
uh,
one of the pathways that they fall.
It was where we had found that the footprints,
the first,
the first go,
the Siskey use in north,
in northern California,
six rivers national forest and Siskiyou wilderness.
So the,
the primary theory when it comes,
what's tomorrow?
Scoot just a little tear.
Right?
There you go.
Perfect.
Sorry.
So is the primary theory about Sasquatch is that it was something along the
lines of a gigantic pikas that was in Asia came down the Bering strait with
humans and that's why there's so many of them.
Habiting the dense rain forest of the Pacific northwest that had just found it
to be ideal habitat.
So just stayed there.
Yeah,
that's,
that's one model.
I mean in gigantic mythic issue have a primate that's the right size and the
right place at the right time to have expanded its range over the Bering land
bridge.
And there were times when that land bridge was a corridor of forest,
not,
not an Arctic Tundra.
So it wasn't like they were migrating,
they were just expanding the range.
I mean each generation would expand into the available.
So from Asia all the way in North America was for us at one point in time
times.
Yeah.
Off and on.
It wasn't all was,
uh,
ice locked.
And so,
uh,
and that would have proceeded probably the time that humans came.
So they were probably here before native Americans are Paleo Indians arrived in
North American.
There's a lot of speculation as to how intelligent it is.
You seem to think it's very apelike,
but I've talked to other folks and thank you.
It's almost a human right then.
It's like something in between us and a chimpanzee.
Yeah.
Well a lot of those people who attribute to,
you know,
primal people or some kind of primitive human,
um,
often also attribute,
uh,
various paranormal qualities there in psychic communication.
They're being taught by them,
you know,
this ancient wisdom and et cetera.
And,
um,
you know,
I don't have any personal experience upon which to evaluate those kinds of
subjects.
How very respectful of you that was so scientific.
That was a nice way to say they're fucking crazy as scientist because you're
learning.
So yeah,
it is a weird thing,
isn't it?
That it,
it falls into that Crystal's channeling energy thing oftentimes gives me Agida I
got to get out of the room when someone starts talking energy and crystals.
I really,
it's,
I'm allergic to it.
We had it yesterday.
Someone started talking about the energy in a safe zone,
safe space.
I was like,
yeah,
I gotta get Outta here.
Yeah.
It's like immediately I feel like I'm threatened.
My sanity is threatened.
I might get sucked in your stupid vortex.
Oh,
come one of you.
Why is that?
Why,
why do you think big foot is aloone magnet?
Do you think it's because when you have people searching up for other things
like butterflies that they theorize that might exist or other undiscovered
species,
they haven't gone completely mad.
But for some reason a lot of these big foot hunters,
it seems like they've lost their mind in this pursuit.
Why?
Why do you think that is?
Well,
I think part of it is that,
um,
uh,
when,
when big foot sort of fell into the lap of academia back in,
well,
it was coincident with the Patterson Gimlin film.
Essentially.
That's when it was thrust under the nose of,
of,
of science,
the scientific community.
Before that it was just a bunch of,
uh,
you know,
loggers stories and foresters stories coming out of the,
the northern woods of British Columbia or northern California,
which was still really wild back then.
Um,
it,
it came at a time that preceded a lot of what we understand now about,
uh,
early human evolution and a great ape natural history.
And it was just,
there was no place to put it.
There was no pigeon to stick this in.
And so it was rejected by the scientific community and then that vacuum came the
amateur fortune seekers or enthusiasts or you know,
those that thought it was left here by a,
or traveling through interdimensional portals or any type of explanation as to
why we aren't finding them.
What makes them different from other common wildlife?
I think what it is is that there's,
there's first of all,
I think there's two different types of people that get attracted to like really
following up on,
on Sasquatch.
And one of them is the loons.
One of them is the people that if it wasn't there,
if they weren't looking for Sasquatch,
they would be looking to remote view or they'd be looking to find out the cause
of chem trails or the,
they would just fall,
they would find some mystery and lock onto it.
Sure.
The other one is courageous people who aren't afraid of looking like kooks
because like yourself,
I think you look at it,
you're obviously a very intelligent man.
You,
you are,
you're an anthropologist,
you're a professor,
you know,
you know what you're talking about.
You look at this and he'd go,
you know what?
Um,
I don't think I can dismiss this.
You know what?
I think there might be something here.
Right,
right.
Even though it sounds crazy to say it.
I'm sorry guys.
This is why there might be something here.
That's right.
What is it?
What's the most compelling piece of evidence if you were trying to convince a
person,
if a person was on the fence and they were like,
well,
she's talked to him,
Belgium.
I don't know.
I mean he seemed like a normal guy.
I'm really big foot.
Like,
tell me in,
in a paragraph what's the most compelling piece of it?
Yeah.
Nice.
Well,
for me,
again,
from my point of expertise,
it's the footprint evidence.
That's what drew me into this because my,
my study of the evolution of human bipedalism,
uh,
prepared me,
I guess you'd say.
I mean,
why,
why wouldn't I be fascinated by the possibility that there's another bike ped
out there?
I mean,
it's a perfect natural experiment to against which to compare and contrast our
own adaptation for walking on two legs,
which is otherwise considered to be unique amongst primates.
And so
was gigantic ethic is thought to be bipedal or is that
bait?
It's in debate.
Grover Krantz made some arguments based on the,
the shape of the jaw,
given the breadth,
the angle of the jaw.
Is that supposed to be a gigantic good chat is that's one of the two of the
examples of the largest species of gigantic Pythagoras,
Blackie Yam and heard of it,
but yeah.
Yeah.
Well yeah,
those are massive,
massive Maulers apps.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Gigantic ethic is blackie.
Yeah.
After the discover,
how rude.
Yeah,
that's what,
that's his name.
Well,
the,
uh,
the thought is that they look more Orangutang liked and gorilla,
is that correct?
Well,
again,
speculation,
because they're found in Asia,
they're part of what we call the Shiva pithy seen radiation,
the thicker enameled apes of which orangutan is the only relic species in
existence today.
Uh,
but again,
there's no way to know.
I mean,
gorillas and chimps are closely related and yet their skulls look quite
different from one another in many ways.
So the foot,
the foot print evidence is in your opinion,
the best evidence.
Right.
And,
uh,
the,
this one that have,
we both have the same one,
right.
What is the origin of this footprint?
This was cast by a deputy sheriff by the name of Dennis Hereford in the 80s in
Grace Harbor County,
Washington state.
So over at the base of the Olympic peninsula.
And,
uh,
he,
was responded to report of a disturbance at a construction site and they're on
that,
that spur road hard packed dirt with a layer of fine pulverize dust from the
movements of the heavy machinery wet down by a rain,
uh,
left this remarkably clear,
imprint.
The,
these are actually desiccation cracks where that wet mud was beginning to dry in
the sun and shrink and crack.
But the extrusion of the mud around the footprint and between the toes and all
left a very,
uh,
very striking,
a facsimile of,
of that foot.
It seems so uniform.
That's where I start to get well skeptical again,
it's,
it's the remarkable,
uh,
conditions when,
you know,
there were photographs of,
of a,
a number of footprints at that site,
including some interesting,
uh,
what I refer to as half tracks that a,
that terminate,
I mean,
the,
the details on here remarkable.
You can see what looks like the head and the base of the fifth metatarsal.
Maybe a little bit of arthritis or some kind of injury to the joints there.
Uh,
this bolt right here then is the key though that that you have on the side of
your foot.
If you left a wet footprint on the cement,
when you came out of the pool,
you'd see that bulge and it's at the,
uh,
it's positioned at the,
what we call the cow Kaneohe cuboid joint,
which is a right there.
Now in Apes,
the,
these two joints across here are much more flexible.
They're adapted to climbing trees.
If this were a chimpanzee would look more like this,
and when they're grasping that branch,
then you have to be able to lever the foot without disrupting the grip.
We've,
we've,
we've changed that all together by relinquishing that grip and incorporating the
big toe into one stiff lever like this.
So the whole foot acts as a,
as a mechanical lever,
but there's moves here.
Remarkably Sasquatch foot appears to have retained that,
uh,
that ape like degree of flexibility,
which is actually pretty,
uh,
elegant adaptation to climbing the on very steep,
rugged mountainous terrain.
What would be the evolutionary benefit of keeping off a human like foot as
opposed to like a gorilla or a chimp where they can grab and climb with their
feet?
Well,
when you're 800 pounds,
it's kind of dangerous to climb up into trees.
Besides what,
what would you look for up there that we don't have fruiting trees in the
coniferous forests.
The fruit element of your diet is in the understory.
The berries in the,
in the shrub layer.
So I've only,
I've heard a couple of people say they climb trees.
You think that's who he is?
Well,
it's probably,
uh,
juveniles maybe to,
you know,
put in a youngster up in a tree in order to get it to away from potential
predators if you're parking it there while you,
while you,
while you're off foraging for example.
But no,
I don't think,
I mean,
just as large male gorillas don't spend much time climbing up in the,
because of fall even,
you know,
even for humans to fall from 10 feet can be fatal if you're experienced rock
climber.
Yeah.
It seems like if you wanted to fake that,
you would have to have a very advanced understanding of gorillas from you.
If you are going to draw that thing and spend the time doing it,
you'd have to have a deep understanding of your really shitty and making a fake
foot and you just got lucky incorporated something that looks remarkably similar
to that metatarsal brick.
I don't know.
That's a pretty,
that's good luck.
I would never throw an accidental metal metatarsal break.
That's not what it is.
And metatarsal breaker bar.
Make that up.
No,
that's right.
Yeah.
How are you going to accidentally draw a metatarsal break,
but at where,
where has calluses,
what?
It seems like its feet are kind of shave down or Fanuc.
Beautiful.
It's like he could it go to the beach right now.
He could go and lay out and people would think he had great feet.
Well,
again,
the,
the conditions of that particular footprint,
we're just really quite remarkable making it very clear imprint.
But um,
you know,
there,
it's,
it's indicated that the sole pat is probably pretty substantial and pretty
thick.
We have some examples of them where they've stepped on rocks or stepped on other
obstructions in that Solo Pad,
that substantial sold pat is able to accommodate those intrusions quite,
uh,
quite remarkably.
But it,
it's,
it's the composite.
You know,
if you take one example and you look at it,
you can dissect it and criticize it and pick it apart and question it.
But when then you see,
you know,
as you point out,
repeated appearances,
not only showing,
for example the midtarsal break,
but,
but these correlated half tracks that,
uh,
where they're running.
I mean,
when,
when we run,
because of our stiff arch,
we,
if we're sprinting not having a,
not exhibiting a heel strike,
we'll leave just an abbreviated footprint because we're up on the ball of our
foot.
Since their foot's flexible,
when they run,
they run like this and it,
and it imprints the entire four part of the foot.
So in other words,
if this individual were running,
it's running track would look like that.
And again,
so,
so that's the question I've often asked.
If this is a,
if this is all just spurious convergences of,
of,
uh,
you know,
would be hoaxers who's passing out the little black book,
giving instructions on how to fake a,
how markably consistent uniform is that.
It's all remarkable.
Remarkably.
Yeah.
Example after example after example.
I mean,
to the point that I took the,
took the leap of,
uh,
intellectual faith,
if you will,
of uh,
uh,
naming the footprints.
There's a convention of taxonomy called Ecmo taxonomy that applies Linnaean
classification schemes to trace evidence like footprints where the maker of the
footprint is unknown.
And so,
uh,
we can now call these footprints a published peer reviewed,
the name,
uh,
anthropoid a Pez Amera Borealis,
which is North American eight foot.
Hmm.
And how silly would that be if it's all fake though whole would be beautiful
sounding Latin name.
It's going to be hard to prove that something that doesn't exist though.
Well,
I guess so,
but that's not what science is all about,
right?
It's special.
It's not proving it's things to exist based on evidence based on the evidence.
And that's it.
It's based on the diagnosis,
uh,
that,
of distinguishing characteristics.
These are not just facsimiles of enlarge human footprints.
Like,
like this example,
you know,
this is actually pretty large.
Uh,
this would represent an individual with a foot is probably in the upper 1% of
the human population.
Have you ever seen skill and Neil shoe?
No,
I haven't.
I've always wanted to do that.
A photo.
I got to remember to get it to you guys.
It's a picture of me,
my face next to Shaquille O'Neal's shoe.
It's bigger than my entire head.
Yeah.
I'm not kidding.
It's bigger than this.
Yup.
Totally.
Totally bigger than that.
So she kalo Neil,
if he wanted to,
it could be the greatest big foot,
big foot.
I mean,
if he went and wandered through the woods,
he's seven feet tall.
He's more than 300 pounds.
Yeah.
He's just slap some fur on him,
put his foot up the same kind of bend.
No,
it wouldn't.
That's the thing.
Even even as large as his foot is and it's not,
it would probably not be in a,
and I don't have his metrics to say this with the certitude,
but I would predict that his foot is not as wide as as this imprint.
Most likely.
Yeah.
Mosley,
he doesn't have the mid tarsal but it doesn't have evidence of that.
He probably has probably been on him from the league.
Last Sasquatch is cause if they ever did catch Sasquatch is and then they found
out the Sasquatches where people very similar to the neanderthals and they
wanted to start playing football,
you'd have a real problem.
It would have been real problem with the problem.
Football would be interesting for once they start banging all the white chicks,
first of all,
why?
That'd be a huge problem.
You're going to have Sasquatch hybrids.
The giant nine foot people,
I'll take him.
SASQUATCH is we'll want to enter into the UFC.
We'd have to make new weight classes.
Everything gets better.
If you add a Sasquatch,
I don't care what it is,
they start showing up or set.
Now,
gorillas are fairly intelligent.
Chimpanzees are intelligent,
dolphins are very intelligent.
We have zero problem locking them up and swimming pools.
Sure.
If we did find a Sasquatch,
do you think because of the bipedal nature of it we there would,
it would probably be some pretty intense debate as to what to do with this
thing.
Well,
are our humanity isn't defined by any one characteristic like bipedalism or
opposable thumbs or you know,
a,
a non divergent big toe.
I mean it's,
it's a composite of a,
of a number of characteristics.
And so,
uh,
we're,
we're beginning to understand that bipedalism,
uh,
was a characteristic of many different species of a very early Hominid and even
some,
uh,
non Hominid ape species.
So,
um,
you don't think that it would be like people go like,
it's an man,
he's standing up straight.
We can't put them in a zoo.
Yeah.
Well I'm sure there'll be some that will say that.
What did,
what do you think they would do?
What is your honest opinion?
Would they detain him?
Well they have to like let it hang out to him for a little while,
see if we can figure out his language or what if it's like killer whale.
Like he's just never figure out their language.
Like,
you know,
they're smart,
be like,
I don't know what you're saying dude.
Eventually just let them loose.
Well,
sure.
The,
there'll be all kinds of ethical questions if we come to that point and what the
outcome will be.
Uh,
you know,
it's really hard to predict.
I mean,
cause then you're not only dealing with the characteristics,
but you're dealing with human reaction,
human attitudes,
political agendas,
whatever.
Yeah.
I'm sorry to what if you to death
what Duncan and I do all day.
I think that's an important question.
I think when you're out there looking for this thing,
you do have to consider that your discovery of the thing might be the worst
thing that ever happened to Sasquatch.
You're his enemies.
Yeah.
Well,
uh,
you know,
that's been there had been suggested to me and brought up numerous times by
various various people.
I,
you know,
and my,
one of my responses is simply the,
the formal recognition,
the discovery of the species isn't suddenly going to make it easy to go out and
shoot a Sasquatch or to catch a Sasquatch is not going to change much at all.
Uh,
you know,
there,
there's a study underway now to,
to examine a extract an examine a DNA from,
from hair samples attributed to Sasquatch.
If,
uh,
if that researcher,
Dr. Bryan Sykes from Oxford,
if he discovers a novel sequence that confirms that there's a species out there,
we don't recognize,
it's not going to change that situation.
We still won't know anything else about them.
DNA will only tell us so much and they tell us about where it fits in the family
tree,
but not what it does on a daily basis or how intelligent it is.
Or
if I'm the president,
okay.
And I come to you and I'm like,
doctor,
Meldrum enough is enough.
We need answers.
We need a Sasquatch research team head up by you,
sir.
Will you accept this position?
And you have unlimited resources to go find Sasquatch.
What's your plan?
Well,
we've actually got an initiative.
Thank you for the segue there.
Uh,
it's entitled the Falcon Project and this is a,
they're going to confuse people.
They're going to think you're looking for birds.
Well,
when I called
put project,
why does it have to be just bad ass tobacco falconry project
you,
it doesn't cut it.
Um,
well the,
the,
the person who is the originator of this notion,
he picked that he tells me just because falcons fly high and see far and the
premise of this approach is to use lighter than air ships.
The helium filled a durable,
so it an unmanned drones,
but with the capability of hovering,
you know,
and uh,
doing a grid search pattern using the state of the art,
uh,
thermal imaging and high resolution,
videography and survey that way.
Why a blimp
though?
I have balloon aside from the fact that it's incredible and I can't think of
anything more psychedelic than to release a balloon into the forest,
to look for bigfoot Zeplin music playing from one time project Falcon.
So that would be the move balloons.
I think this is a not,
not a,
not an entirely novel.
These techniques are being used in wildlife survey studies already.
I mean there,
there are companies that have popped up that uh,
that provide the service to government agencies,
a fishing game and so forth.
Um,
it's just the combination with this particular type of an air ship.
But I think it's the way to get at a,
the daily behaviors and,
and ranging patterns and so forth to these creatures on the ground.
You're looking for that proverbial moving needle in a haystack.
We're going to obviously combine the effort with ground insertion teams that
will attempt to follow up to find trace and physical evidence evidence.
And how many people do you need?
I'm the president.
Remember?
Yeah.
Unlimited budget.
Not that many.
We,
uh,
let's see.
Uh,
a half dozen could do this and we're going to need you to take all these people
away from the DEA and give them real jobs.
This is the move.
Take the people from the DEA and put them in the Ba.
Now,
if the primal people though we may have the problems with the social rights and
so forth,
if they are people,
that does become an issue,
right?
Region.
Yeah.
Well there's people that have said that they've shot them.
And then of course now they've passed laws saying in certain states it's
actually illegal to shoot a Sasquatch.
It is.
Yeah.
Not In all 50 right?
No,
it's,
it's usually by county.
Uh,
so Bennett county where I come from,
we have a safe haven.
Yep.
Wow.
Now if someone did shoot a Sasquatch and your county,
what's the,
what's the penalty?
It's like a parking ticket.
They would go to jail.
They were kind of vague on that.
Yeah.
What the penalty actually was.
I guess we'd have to see that raises the question of,
of their status,
whether they're non human or human.
Why have there been no bobbies?
Why have there been no skulls?
Right?
Like has there been no hair?
Why?
Why have there been lots of hair,
lots of hair,
but none of it like substantiated as in fact by way of DNA,
by way of morphology.
We've got hair that can't be attributed to any,
any commonly known wildlife that has consistent morphological characteristics,
one of which is a hollow or a cellular Mandala.
The central core,
which makes getting DNA from a hair that simply shed,
that doesn't have an actively dividing follicle.
Uh,
very difficult.
Very challenging.
But it was proven to be actual real hair.
Oh yes,
definitely.
Absolutely.
So it's an unknown animals hair.
Right.
Do you know whether,
what kind of animal is that known primate like primate will definitely,
well in the sense that Ma non primate mammals for bearing mammals of North
America have have for rather than simply hair,
that means they have guard hairs.
These long course tapering a guard hairs that provide mechanical and then the
underlying that differentiated layer of insulating here.
Very fine.
Uh,
underfur that's like down.
Yes,
exactly.
Yeah.
Like down on a,
on a bird bird has,
they have down in flight feathers,
um,
in,
in mammals it's guard hairs.
And a underfur primates though don't have that differentiation.
They have hair that's kind of like a modified guard here,
but it's untaped it as long parallel tips,
worn tips.
No sign of ever been having been cut,
trimmed with a Flowbee that together.
So squads with flow,
we got downs.
What color is the hair?
It ranges.
We have an,
it correlates with the reported colors of a Sasquatch is seen by eye witnesses
from a,
almost white
almost.
Why is it the,
the ETI or actual Sasquatch?
Almost white.
Uh,
well,
SAS,
we're still still talking about Sasquatch.
So there had been white Sasquatch described by witnesses.
Yeah,
rare.
But that nevertheless seen the,
all the way to black,
the DNA on the hair comes up with nothing.
Well,
it's difficult to get DNA because there's,
you know,
the way hair is constructed that you have a cuticle and then you have a layer
called the cortex and then a central core and in,
in,
uh,
if,
if that core or mandala has cells stacked up in it,
then that's usually where the DNA is extracted from in animals that don't have,
uh,
a mandala present as cellular Modela,
then you have very little,
um,
nuclear material of the sale left in that,
in that shaft,
in that Keratin chat.
And so getting any DNA in order to sequence it is,
is almost impossible.
What are the party poopers say that,
that Harris,
well,
they don't,
they say they say there's no evidence one way or the other.
So it's basically you've got this hair that hasn't been identified,
but you know,
identifying hair's kind of more art than science because even on our bodies,
we have hair that differs in appearance,
had hair,
beard,
hair.
Exactly.
Pubic.
You had to bring that up.
Mo Harris.
Um,
so it's different.
Yeah,
it's definitely different.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
In the inside nose hairs,
what the fuck are those all about?
Those are ridiculous
eyelashes,
eyebrows.
So it's going to fit.
Here's another thing,
in the same way that I can't imagine someone taking the time to fake those
footprints,
no one's going to go through the woods with a bag of weird hair and scatter it
through the forest.
No,
but you might pretend you found it.
You don't have to go scatter it if you're attending,
you found it yourself.
But there's a lot of people that are full of Poop,
right.
We know that.
You know that.
I know that and this,
this subject particularly attracts a lot of them.
I'm sure you're aware of the gentleman in Montana recently that was killed.
This hilarious but not hilarious cause poor fellows,
just trying to hope somebody,
he had a big foot suit on,
got hit by one car,
driven by a 17 year old girl and then run over by another car.
Joe By 16 year old girl.
He's an asshole.
He's trying to scare kids,
you know,
that could cause a wreck.
Anyway.
Well Yeah,
look,
I have a 16 year old daughter.
If he gets good,
she got scared by an asshole and fake bigfoot suit and got into a wreck,
I'd be pissed.
Yeah,
sure.
So the world got a little lighter as Bill Hicks would say.
We lost a moron.
The um,
this,
this phenomenon for whatever reason is,
well,
I guess there's a bunch of reasons why people would want to hoax it.
First of all,
notoriety.
Second of all,
because it's fun.
And third of all,
because it's so similar to us.
It's not like trying to w if we tried to hooks the loch ness monster,
that would be a pain in the ass.
But,
uh,
you know,
you're a fairly big guy,
will put you in a big monkey suit,
puts you at a distance,
you know,
have you wandering around,
as long as there's nothing we could line up for perspective,
you'd look like a little,
you know,
we can get it off.
Oh,
shut it off.
Oh yeah.
There's lots of myths.
Identifications.
I mean,
that's one of the problems of,
of eyewitness testimony is you,
you're not only,
uh,
at the mercy of,
of the witness's credibility,
but,
but honestly,
even if they're sincere and genuine in what they think they saw,
your,
you have to evaluate their ability to evaluate their experience,
to interpret what they think.
Yeah.
My memory's poop.
My memories.
It gets worse all the time.
She'll,
and especially because since we started doing the podcast and um,
you know,
just having all this information like rattled at me every day and dealing with
having these long form three hour conversations,
I don't remember who I said what with or when and I confuse stories.
Sure.
Yeah.
You know what also,
and I don't know if there's any statistics for it,
but I heard that there's this statistic that 40% of the people at Disneyland or
on ecstasy at any given time,
I heard that that's like a statistic,
like the number of people on psychedelics back in the same way in the forest.
How many people camping or hi,
what's the percentage?
Cause I think it's 90% of the people who go camping or high.
And I don't think that this discounts the fact that there's big foot.
But I would say that most of the people who see big foot,
if they're out in the woods,
they're probably stoned on top of it.
It's possible that they are.
But I think another issue is that you may only be able to contact big foot when
you're high.
I are.
Maybe that's it.
Maybe it's the cause of my problem northwest.
We need to get you on some mushrooms on the Pacific northwest is overflowing
with psilocybin mushrooms.
I mean they're everywhere,
right?
It's so rainy up there.
It's just like the Purtell perfect fertile ground for them and a lot of people
go up there to to gather those things.
Now if you were up there and you were gathering those things,
maybe that puts your mind into a certain frequency when big like,
I know this guy's trip and let's go fuck with them.
And then bigfoot chosen sal.
Hey Dude.
Plus pretty territorial.
So maybe they're just making up the stories to scare off the competition.
Are
they really hold their mushroom people would be the least territory.
Oh No,
there it's big.
How do you know sir?
I've run into a lot of Maro Miranda knickers and run into him.
He hasn't called them.
Hey,
meet me here with a bag.
I've run into you and you've run into my chat,
my cash.
I wonder if big foot eats those mushrooms.
I of course he does.
Why wouldn't he?
Smart.
The craziest trip is the trip and with big bigfoot being big flat.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Tripping with bigfoot is definitely a great kids,
but I wonder if big foot is pissed at all.
The wolves killing the elk,
you know,
they was like serious issues with wolves,
killing elk and deer now because they reintroduced the,
they took an un Un Canada Wolf,
which is a larger version of the gray wolf,
and introduced them to Idaho and all these different areas and now they're
having a problem.
These things are running rampant.
There's thousands of them.
They're just massive packs killing things.
They just opened the season in Idaho on,
on wolves that that disturbs the shit out of people.
And that's just a wolf and it's because we,
we see it as,
you know,
as a dog,
I got to say,
I think that you are a courageous person because you seem very level headed.
You seem completely logical and rational with all this stuff.
And I think it must take an awful lot of patients to constantly end up in
interviews with stoners asking of big foot eats mushrooms.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
there's,
there's a lighter side.
I've,
I've got,
I've got a notebook with all the,
uh,
all the lighter stories that I'll publish one day.
All right.
Now here's something that you said.
A chapter unfortunately disturbs me.
Here's something that you said that unfortunately disturbs me and that is,
you talked about the Patterson footage as if it wasn't bs,
that Patterson footage.
To me,
it looks like a blurry video of a dude in a monkey suit.
Well,
if it looks that blurry to you,
then you haven't seen the best,
uh,
renditions of best copies of is on,
are they online?
Uh,
there's one,
there's one that's online.
What's the best one?
Well,
I'm not sure if I can call it off top of my head,
but the producer of the show just looked at me like,
oh no,
here we go.
Because he knows I got to thank for the prednisone footage.
Well,
one of the things,
we're fine.
We've got a lot of good stuff already.
One of the things that's interesting is every time the film is a sailed by a
critic or a,
or a pretender,
uh,
to be the man in,
in,
uh,
in the suit such as Bob or autonomous,
right.
Um,
the,
uh,
you know,
it seems that that new technologies have become available in the intervening
period and they're applied.
One of those was,
uh,
the,
it was digital imagery by scanning that film digitally.
The,
uh,
the image could be,
the color could be channel split.
Uh,
we know that the,
the,
the lens that was used was not corrected for chromatic aberration.
So different colors refracting different inch wrench really through that Lens.
You sure talk a good game,
Mr. Somatic aberrations,
dare you,
you
split,
you know,
just well,
just pop a mushroom and you'll understand what I'm talking about.
Are these rainbow colors.
We split the colors.
We can subtract away the least clear channels and just limit the image to the
sharpest imagery and a boy,
I tell Ya,
you see that image as you've never seen it before.
Um,
and there are details.
I,
I've,
you know,
I'm,
I'm working right now with a gentleman who is a former Hollywood makeup artists
and fat and I'm a costume fabricator.
You'll bill months.
He's also very good with,
uh,
with computer graphics,
with photogrammetry and we're doing some really interesting work on the film.
But you know,
when you stop and think about the materials that were available,
1967,
they didn't have four way stretch for,
they just had for cloth,
which when you make a costume out of it,
even a padded costume,
it looks like pajamas.
It doesn't look like a fitted,
a fitted.
It doesn't look real to me.
That big guy walk like a gorilla walks like somebody who's late for a meeting.
Not only that,
there's not a girl,
there's the context.
There's something about,
uh,
human beings where when a human being is wearing a suit or you,
you see a human being that's pretending to be something that they're not,
it doesn't seem right.
They walk like a human.
You will think that you see that thing walk.
That to me feels like a human being.
I've seen chimps walk on two legs.
I've seen gorillas,
I've seen primates move,
they move differently than people do.
They have a completely different anatomical structure.
They feel different.
When you watched him,
this feels like an asshole pretending to be big foot.
Well,
I'll sell.
Here's the,
let me just play big foot advocate here.
There is the possibility though.
I mean if you're,
if you're shooting a big foot hoax video,
you're going to walk better than that.
This whoever did this is like,
it's like he's in between.
Takes going to use the bathroom or something.
Well this is just a dude does it with Bob Hieronymus,
the guy who at the says it's him.
He's just a guy who was friends with Bob Patterson and we've already been over
the fact that Patterson wrote a bad check to pay for the very camera that day.
He's a shady character.
He wasn't exactly the salt of the earth.
And he went looking,
I'm sorry.
But he went,
he went looking for big foot and then found bigfoot.
That sounds so ridiculous.
But if you're gonna take the time to go out in the forest with whatever that big
suit is,
and to film yourself walking through the woods to make a hoax,
big foot video,
you're going to try to walk more like a gorilla or some supernatural thing.
The stride of that thing is so bad and theme sell fake that it makes me believe
that it's real.
I,
well,
I got baked one night at the Ice House and I was convincing myself for 20
minutes.
I mind fuck myself.
And I'd completely convinced myself that it was real.
And then I woke up.
I was like,
that's ridiculous.
That's the kind of monkey suit.
As Dr Melvin though,
what he was studying,
the four big
foot,
because it's Germane to his,
okay,
we'll get to that.
We'll get to that.
But the,
this,
this foam,
have you ever looked at it and thought it was fake?
Hmm.
Never.
Well,
I mean,
I've,
I've questioned whether it was authentic or not,
but I never come to a conclusion that it must have been faked.
It's the holy grail of big foot footage.
Uh,
well,
yeah,
but that's not,
that's not the reason.
I know.
I'm Oh sure it has set the bar.
I guess I,
that's why I would rather look at it that it,
it sets the bar as high as,
as it is for photographic evidence and anything that falls short of it,
since we're still debating it is certainly not going to tip the scale.
It would be devastating.
Uh,
no,
it wouldn't because we still have this dozens and dozens,
hundreds of footprints that fill my lab that,
that form the basis of my conclusion.
But I would think it would just be devastating just because people would be
upset.
They were claiming that it wasn't real.
It was real.
That would be,
you go wise,
there will be a crusher is such a fringe belief anyway,
right?
Sure,
sure.
But if all I had to go on Wa was the,
uh,
the correlated footprints were the correlated footprints from that film side.
That would be enough to convince me that it's authentic.
Really.
The correlator Phil footprints were very good.
Well,
yeah,
this example that's so is that one from Bluff Creek?
That is that.
So that's from the Patterson footage.
That is man,
that exhibits that whole midtarsal and talk about it.
And you can see that kinematic,
that action in the foot of the film subjects.
So it looks to me when I watch it,
it looks like a guy walking with ice skates on.
You know when you have ice skates can't walk.
Right.
Well that's it.
That's that effective.
The compliancy of the gate,
they don't walk.
You know,
you said it doesn't look like a chimp.
It doesn't look like a gorilla.
And that's absolutely true because gorillas and chimps are quadrupedal.
They're not bipeds.
Well actually I said it looks like a person.
That's what I see when you watch a chimp move and you watch a gorilla move,
they don't look like human beings.
This looks like a human being.
Right.
And,
and that similarity is largely due to the fact that this is another bypass that
uses a mode of locomotion that's very similar but not identical to our own.
And one of those differences you,
you pointed out with the ice skating is that effect of the compliant gate.
You know,
one of the things you notice often notice in,
in many of these footprints is compared to a human,
there's not a real distinctive,
uh,
he'll impression and a ball impression,
which is the result of our arched foot,
that constant straights pressure under those ends of the arch.
So we have a heel strike and a toe off when we walk.
This creature because of its great mass,
has to distribute his weight over a larger surface area so it walks more flat
footed without an arch.
And then you've got the action that mid tarsal brake,
you can see here's the deepest part of the footprint right there.
And then the pressure Ridge,
the pressure release that's pushed up behind it.
But in order to also reduce those reaction forces,
that impact of the step,
it walks with a slightly bent ankle,
knee and hip.
And so instead of the head bobbing along like we walk when we're walking briskly
down,
you know,
the,
the sidewalk,
uh,
smooth.
Exactly.
I've had eye witnesses when they saw it.
They thought it was either levitating floating through the air.
One described it,
he said,
look like it was on a bicycle because its head was just moving horizontally
through space as it was,
uh,
as it was walking so smoothly.
So that's a,
that's an interesting distinction.
But to my eye,
that's,
that confirms the credibility rather than refutes it.
That's interesting.
Still excited to do it in a monkey suit.
Well,
it does at first clients,
you know,
but when you start looking at things like,
you're a bodybuilder,
the attachment of the [inaudible],
I am
the attachment of the Trapezius.
On the back of the head.
You can see the traps come down to those massive shoulders.
You can see the definition of the deltoid.
Or you see a dude who has football pads on inside a gorilla.
You have such a smooth voice in such an easy way of talking about this.
You could make me believe in the Leprechaun.
None of corn.
You mean you don't,
it's easy to get me to start believing,
man.
I,
I started looking at it over and over again.
I'd be watching the video the entire time.
We're talking like maybe,
maybe man,
nobody would want it to be real more than me.
That's why it disturbs me that I think it's fake because man,
I would want that to be real so bad.
Almost as much as you,
you first meet.
Like one of the interesting thing,
you know,
Roger's no longer here to defend himself,
but Bob Gimlin,
his partner is,
and Bob was kind of pulled in on this.
He was a,
he was the friend who had the necessary horse trailer and equipment and so forth
to make this kind of happen.
And he got pulled in.
He was interested.
He heard the stories that Roger told him and went out riding with him every now
and again over by Mount St Helens and Mount Adams when you're near where they
lived in Yakima.
But,
uh,
they,
they had gone down there specifically because there had been footprints
discovered a month earlier,
a long line of tracks.
If three individuals a of 15 inch,
which I'm convinced was her,
and then a 13 and an 11 inch,
which probably were,
were juvenile offspring of hers that were just in tow.
Uh,
they'd been down there for two weeks already.
It's not like they just went down in two whole weeks.
Wow.
They put in the time they really deserve finding the shortest video footage ever
of a giant ape like man thing.
Well it's,
it's dumb luck.
There's always a certain element of dumb luck or,
or,
yeah,
of course you can play it off either side of it,
but you got away the,
you know,
even if even if you dismiss it on the basis or,
or if you a hedge on the basis of those circumstantial evidence is then you got
to account for the film.
You know,
that was the year that planted the apes came out.
Now that was the state of the art in the industry for costumes.
That has never been in the industry.
We quickly past costumes and,
and if we were going to do it now we do it with CGI.
No one would even tackle that with a costume.
All right,
let me play devil's advocate real quick.
Even the really good footage,
let's be honest,
it's blurry.
If you went to see a movie and it looked like that,
you'd be pissed.
Sure.
Shit movie.
Are you making?
He came to see what's going on.
It's all blurry.
The trees,
you can't see the leaves.
Everything is like washed out.
It's very difficult to distinguish really,
really closely exactly what you're looking at.
Well,
there's enough detail that that you can see the,
the,
you know the deep set eyes.
You can see the nose,
you can see the split of the mouth.
You can see the see something.
What about Bob Hieronymus,
the guy who says that he was in the suit and the guy who when he walks looks
like bigfoot.
Well,
he doesn't actually,
one interesting thing.
No,
he doesn't look anything like it.
His limb proportions are completely off on,
is not wearing a suit.
Here's a funny little telltale hip telltale sign.
Okay?
You notice that when he tries to imitate the Patterson film,
he walks like in Egypt,
he turns his,
his backhand back far.
There was a,
there was a frame from the Patterson film that was widely published sometime
after,
it was actually a copy that was in the possession of a Renee to Hinden and it
had a little blemish on the copy that made it look like there was almost like a
thumb and forefinger making an okay sign that made it look like that hand was
turned back like this.
That's an artifact of the,
of the copy.
The hand is actually positioned like this.
The palm doesn't face backwards,
but Hieronymus trying to exemplify,
trying to emulate the posture exaggerates this Egyptian hand posture may stop
that widely.
Uh,
published.
Publicized sounds to me like someone's got a little confirmation bias
wants it to be real.
Oh,
no,
it's,
it,
it sounds that way because I'm throwing out things that are based on their
exhaustive evaluation of the film.
Exhaustive evaluation of Bob [inaudible] walk like an Egyptian hands.
Oh,
sure.
Yeah.
I'd have to buy everything that he's allowed to be replicated or
can I throw my pinky and with a doctor here?
Please do.
I just want to say,
look,
here's the thing.
If I'm going out in the woods and I've got this futuristic big foot suit and
horses and a camera,
I'm going to walk in a weirder way.
I'm not going to walk into buddy,
right?
May I would walk exactly like this guy in the monkey suit.
You would walk like that.
I would never know number one about the head movement thing.
I wouldn't know that this was some kind of primordial thing.
So these people seem to have deeply studied it to make something seem so fake or
it's just walked straight and they filmed it all blurry and then we add all
these things to her.
Why is it exhibiting behavior that's so uncharacteristic of every other
Sasquatch sighting?
Every single Sasquatch there,
like in the middle of
the woods,
they don't come out in the open and you don't stand there and when they walk,
why would they walk that way?
Why wouldn't it go right back in the woods?
Why is it walking diagonally?
Well,
when you have to give you a nice long view of itself as he got your camera,
it seems that way seems staged.
One,
there's several possibilities.
Just,
just give you an unapologetic.
Okay.
First one is,
is bullshit,
right?
First one we looked here this bullshit,
but the other is that one of them is that a,
first you have to know the lay of the land there and we've been to the site,
we've surveyed the,
the line of marks,
the trees,
the stumps and so forth.
This is a very deep canyon with very steep walls at that point.
There's a wide girth that there,
because of the flood that he essentially scoured out that that creek bed and
left that very convenient if you will,
a sandbar where those beautiful tracks could be laid down.
But it made a beeline up,
uh,
upstream,
some distance,
cross the creek and,
and once it was passed that steep,
narrow,
it opened up a bit and that's where it immediately went up to higher elevation.
One explanations that's been offered is that it was,
now remember I said that a month earlier,
there were actually three sets of tracks,
possibly two juveniles.
Those aren't obvious here in,
in this footage.
And,
and like I said,
I'm quite convinced that her tracks match those of the other 15 inch set of
tracks.
So she's obviously a female if it's real.
Uh,
and so she,
if she has some young and toe one behavior of,
of um,
you know,
that exemplifies the maternal instinct is that broken wings syndrome where the
mother walks off nonchalantly to lead the intruders away from the sequestered
offspring.
Oh,
so the offspring are over here,
so she's like straight making them follow her and her offspring.
Yeah.
Isn't that an odd thing to do in a place that's filled with predators and then
you seem to predators,
that's how they do it.
They would,
well,
you know what,
how,
how much,
uh,
of a,
of a threat are humans,
you know what I mean?
I would think they're a huge threat,
which is why Sasquatch is a hiding.
Otherwise,
if they came down and got food from us,
we would feed him every day.
Sure.
I mean,
I feed squirrels,
dude.
You tell me.
I wouldn't feed a Sasquatch Sasquatch shut up in the yard.
Sure.
How have they avoided trail cams?
Well,
uh,
there are a lot of animals that are capable of avoiding trail cams.
I mean,
there,
there's actually a growing literature showing everything from,
uh,
you know,
coyotes specifics,
especially,
uh,
other predators like fields that,
exhibit avoidance behavior,
whether it's a electronic emissions,
whether it's light leakage,
whether it's sent,
whether it's just the novelty of something on that regular use trail that wasn't
there the day before.
Probably smells like piano or something.
I had a,
I had a friend,
uh,
he's a wildlife biologist.
He's been working over in Southeast Asia and he said recently a BBC crew came
over and they wanted to get images of elephants and they put out 18 trail cams.
The elephants found in destroyed over half of them.
Wow.
So elephants
are very smart.
Exactly.
Kind of strange how smart they are.
No problem.
Locking them up,
Ma.
Well,
yeah.
Again,
but it's a,
it's a question up in part of rarity of solitary city and intelligence and
behavior and so on.
You know,
isn't it possible that this creature has evolved the ability to hide that,
wait,
let me ask that again.
Isn't it possible that this creature has evolved beyond other beings when it
comes to the ability to hide?
Maybe whatever this is,
is super advanced and camouflaging itself in a way that we've never seen.
Well,
it's possible.
I don't think that you,
we really have to resort to extraordinary explanations for it at hiding.
I mean,
other animals are very capable of remaining undetected.
It's just a matter of odds.
I mean,
how many times when you have gone out or,
you know,
people,
uh,
I just drove through Yellowstone,
you know,
and got caught up in these traffic jams where people would,
um,
uh,
stop to see the bear or the bison.
But there are hundreds of bison out there that are never seen,
you know,
but when you have that many scattered across the landscape,
the chances of bumping into one increase.
But if you're talking about a very rare animal,
you know,
something like a wolverine or a Fisher or Martin,
you can talk to people who have spent lots of time in the woods who have never
had a side into one of those animals.
So it's just,
you know,
for me it's,
it's a matter of statistics,
just,
just probabilities of,
of encountering.
But Gee,
you don't,
if we don't see something move,
a vertical line,
especially is,
is very cryptic in the woods.
We're,
we're usually the scene things that are horizontally oriented,
like the back of a deer or a bear or whatever.
But it's kind of like that a closing scene in Harry and the Hendersons when
suddenly the,
how dare you quote Harry and the Hendersons when you come on a show to talk to
us about serious science.
By the way,
that's a pretty obscure reference pal for most normal folks,
almost normal folks.
And not like quoting Harry and the Hendersons.
And what happened in Harry and Anderson on the final scene when Harry's sent
back out into the woods,
then out from the landscape emerges his whole family.
And they were standing there right in front of you,
but they're just because they were still,
you didn't see them then as soon as they put cute when it's a movie.
Well,
right.
But yeah,
but there's,
there's truth to that.
We really pick up our,
our brain zeroes in on a movement,
you know,
a movement in that.
But if it's absolutely still,
uh,
we have a hard time sometimes in Predator.
Yeah,
exactly.
Another one.
How much credence do you give to the idea that they're all over the country?
Oh,
very little.
Um,
they're,
their distribution,
again,
assuming they exist for a moment,
is very ecologically based.
So we don't find them in the middle of wheat fields of Kansas or,
or,
uh,
you know,
West Texas.
We find them where sufficient rainfall to support coniferous forests and
understory that that's productive enough to support large omnivore.
So if you looked at a few,
got a guide to mammals and flipped open to American black bear,
for example,
looked at the distribution,
or better yet,
flip open to my field guide,
Sasquatch field guy.
I have a Sasquatch guild guide,
isn't it?
It's yet.
So,
um,
but there is a,
if I can find it here,
there is a distribution map of a hypothetical distribution.
Where can I get one of those?
Um,
well I can give you a address to send a check to and get one dairy.
He just got money out of you.
How much this is a,
well with the,
with postage it would be 1150.
I'll take it in the United States for you.
Merry Christmas buddy.
Anyway,
but uh,
there there's a distribution map and what's interesting is it's very similar to
the distribution Matt for American black bears because there's another omnivore
that needs a certain amount of,
uh,
of productive habitat and a,
you know,
there's lots of space on that map where there's no,
uh,
there's no evidence of any of any Sasquatch existing you.
So your,
your,
um,
your belief is that you're dealing with the Pacific northwest primarily and then
possibly a few other spots like Connecticut Shit.
Well,
the,
the backside of the apple is,
so if you go across the boreal forest to Canada,
right down the backside of the Appalachian in New England states,
Connecticut,
well it could be that's really densely populated state kind of hard,
but down the backside of the appellation,
even eastern Ohio,
it's PR.
It's surprising if you've ever been there.
Yeah.
There's some support for,
so you believe Ohio,
maybe?
Possibly Pennsylvania.
Uh,
yeah.
Western Pennsylvania,
Florida,
Florida.
Sure.
Really some of that.
So now there's a lot of,
my experience has been,
uh,
and for a long time I simply used the,
you know,
the easy caveat that I didn't have the time or resources to consider all the
evidence east of the Mississippi,
but my experience has been that the data that has come from those areas that
might corroborate such sidings is pretty scant.
And there's a lot of things that are just not credible.
What,
like math,
like Meth,
a lot of math and,
but I think if you're seeing,
can you talk a little bit about the way that at big foot smells?
Well,
yeah.
Oftentimes in the [inaudible],
you know,
as a moniker that,
uh,
the derives from that suppose that stench.
But,
uh,
it's interesting when you look at this,
statistics collated from lots and lots of sightings.
A stench is only reported in about 10% of the,
of the circle of the signings.
That suggests to me that they don't continually smell badly to our,
to our nose,
but that they're capable of exuding the smell.
A great apes like bike chimps and gorillas have very well developed axillary.
Oregon's,
um,
the,
uh,
apple cringe sweat glands.
The things that when we sweat,
when we're nervous as opposed to the watery sweat that is used in evaporative
cooling and,
um,
when animals are wind like gorillas,
Djing,
Dian Fossey rather,
excuse me.
She describes the first time up silver back,
bluff charged her,
came barreling down at her.
She hunkered down,
you know,
an averted her gaze and,
and it stopped just a foot short of her,
but she said she was nearly bowled over by this locker room sent that it was
emitting.
And,
uh,
and she was probably a meeting one to by that point,
I imagine
horrifying.
That would be,
yeah,
you got a giant silver back charging you exactly.
So close.
You can smell it stank.
So,
so whether it's fear or um,
uh,
tension or intimidation,
they're probably capable of exuding that kind of smell under those
circumstances.
Just like a skunk,
just like skunk
yard.
The other night and a,
I had explained to my daughter that you can't get too close to the Scott.
There was a skunk wandering in the backyard.
We have chickens and the skunk is found out we had chickens,
by the way,
skunks are murderers.
Okay.
They're very carnivorous.
They're predators and they were looking to kill my chickens and they actually
drink their blood.
That's how they get ganged their neck and drink their blood.
So cute little skunks,
pepe Le Pew,
and not so much the little monsters,
but you know,
I had explained to where like I go,
if it gets you,
the smell is unbelievably bad and you know,
she's five.
She's like,
I don't even know what you're talking about.
It doesn't smell at all.
I'm like,
it can smell it's smells on purpose.
Sure.
That's a weird thing.
The ability to spray that stuff on purpose and they can only do it.
I heard they can only do it 10 times a year.
Skunks.
Yeah.
They can't,
they only have a certain amount that they could spray.
So whenever they spray,
they have to mean that rate of production.
What's fascinating is that smell that,
um,
that we can recognize in just a small parts per million.
That's how dogs smell loss.
Oh yeah.
Men Not so bad,
I'm sure.
But they can smell the availability to recognize us the way we could recognize
skunks,
which is,
it really puts it in perspective because he's very few smells that are like
that,
that are squirted out by a small animal that can spread for blocks and blocks.
You know that when you're driving,
you're in your car,
you smell it through your events.
Right.
It's super powerful.
So I'm mostly Pacific northwest or anywhere where there's large desk for us.
Who's the most credible I witnessed that you've ever talked to?
Oh,
there'd been several.
One that,
that always comes to mind when I'm asked that though is,
uh,
a lady by the name of the Julie Davis who had a remarkable encounter in the
South San Juan's of,
uh,
of Colorado.
She's a very avid goat packer and she's hiked the entire continental divide
trail through Colorado.
And,
uh,
her story was,
was in the Denver post 'em in a big feature article,
but,
and I've,
I've spent over a month,
uh,
in the,
in the back country with her and a couple other researchers and got to know her
very well and been in her home,
heard her,
recount her,
her,
uh,
recollections over a campfire and,
and,
um,
you know,
when,
when someone has a shares that kind of experience or,
well,
hers is worth retelling very quickly.
She was off trail,
uh,
with her goats and a couple of dogs.
The dogs were acting up.
She suspected maybe that she was being stalked by a bear.
And,
and there still are grizzlies in the supposedly still are grizzlies.
This is the area of the,
the so called Ghost Grizzlies where they,
they think they're extinct.
And then a hunter shoots one and it's a female and she's awfully obviously
suckled the cubs.
So there still are some grizzlies out there perhaps.
And what part of the south?
The Colorado Rockies.
Uh,
the Wyman.
Which country in the South San Juan's.
But uh,
at one point she,
um,
her dogs were again acting up.
She was kind of on,
on the lookout.
She didn't want her dogs to tangle with the bear,
so she was taking the dogs towards the tent and stepped into the tent and got
her pepper spray.
And suddenly the goats approached the tent.
They weren't looking at her though.
They were looking up above the tent.
And so she stepped out thinking she was going to confront a bear and have to
spray it.
And they're standing right behind her tent.
So about from me to you,
I'm just a small dome tent is this eight foot tall hairy figure locking eyes
with her.
And this is in the middle of the afternoon in broad daylight.
And I have close quarters.
She said,
um,
she looked at her,
it looked at the goats,
it looked back at her.
I mean,
this was apparently fascinated by these funny looking animals it hadn't
encountered before perhaps.
And uh,
she said she had a sort of a subliminal,
a impression suddenly that,
that I won't bother you if you won't bother me.
And uh,
she said that,
uh,
when she had that wreck,
that that sense it's demeanor kind of softened the edge,
sort of went off.
And at that point a second one that was standing right behind it,
a slightly smaller one,
peered out from around the bigger one and they sat and kind of stared at each
other for,
you know,
probably what seemed like an eternity.
It was just a few seconds and then they'd both turned and they headed off
towards the tree line and disappear.
We going,
yeah,
exactly.
Have have a goat.
She didn't,
uh,
she didn't dare tell anyone for years about it because of the fear of the stigma
and God,
I would give enough.
That's true.
Yeah,
exactly.
Not even to it myself,
just to know that she was telling the truth.
Well,
and as I said,
it's one thing to,
you know,
in your position to sit and,
well,
yeah,
you know,
it could be,
it couldn't be right,
but when,
when you,
when it's someone that you have come to know and you count as a friend,
as a close acquaintance,
then you know,
oh,
well you were mistaken.
You know,
it was just a bear standing upright from 10 feet away.
You A,
you know,
you just imagined it or you've misinterpreted it.
Rain blew a fuse or you're lying to me,
you know,
you're just making this up for attention.
There.
We spoke to one woman who had Barbara who had an incredibly compelling story.
Yup.
Hmm.
So we,
yeah,
I've,
I've talked to people that have stories and make you just go,
whoa boy.
Which I knew well,
yeah,
people are having experiences.
Again,
it comes back to this issue of,
of how do you interpret those experiences?
How credible are they?
That's really going to be where the madness is because you can't discount unique
experiences.
You really can't.
You can't.
And,
but I always kind of push for the corroboration.
You know,
I want to see an associated footprint.
I want to see a strand of hair that,
that matches that sort of a standard or that,
uh,
that,
um,
arc type of,
of the hair of Sasquatch that that's kind of the,
the,
the gold standard you'd see,
I guess.
Um,
because then,
then there's another dimension to it that takes some of the subjectivity out of
the evaluation of the experience for me anyway.
Is this your full time job?
No,
no,
no.
I mean,
I'm,
I teach,
I do research.
I publish on a hominid evolution and bipedalism.
Um,
it,
it takes a significant amount,
but I see it as one facet,
a very complimentary facet to my,
my other research,
some of the insights that I've gained from studying carefully.
The Sasquatch footprints have actually,
uh,
fueled new interpretations of some of the Hominid footprint evidence that have,
that have,
uh,
caused me to advocate some different alternate interpretations of some of that
early evidence besides big foot.
What are the other big foot like creatures that you believe possibly exist?
Right.
Well there that,
you know,
there's the reports of all,
all around the globe of,
of different sorts of things,
not all related.
Now,
interestingly,
there's reports of very Sasquatch,
like creatures in eastern Russia and China and even down in Southeast Asia.
Uh,
in fact,
you could go up from Southeast Asia,
Cross Mine,
Amar,
northeast India,
along the foothills of the Himalayas up around the premiere.
And Altai ranges on the border in Mongolia.
Even as far a west is the caucuses between the Caspian and black seas.
There are these gigantic reports and evidence of gigantic footprints left by
large bipedal creatures.
Very similar to Sasquatch.
Mid tarsal braked in the footprints.
Well,
we have a much scanter fossil record.
They resemble,
I mean,
one of the tracks from the Caucasus that a research effect.
I'm going to the caucuses this August,
uh,
to work with this researcher who came back with a footprint that was cast by a
villager,
uh,
from a long line of tracks that,
that most of the village witnessed of a big hairy creature that walked to walk
through this,
um,
this,
uh,
fallow field.
Um,
they,
they resemble remarkably the Sasquatch footprint.
Uh,
so this might be the former range of gigantic pithiness or giant per anthropics
or some other hominid.
Um,
then there's,
there's the Himalayan Yeti and a,
there is unfortunately scant evidence for it.
I've gone through as systematically as possible and evaluated all the footprint
evidence attributed Yeti.
Much of it's just unintelligible.
The snow,
you know,
the prince of melted out or sublimated,
where the snow evaporates at the high altitude.
Uh,
another significant fraction or bears absolutely bears.
And it boils down to probably two specimens,
the famous,
uh,
shipped and photo from the mainland glacier back in the fifties.
What's the name of that?
Uh,
Eric Shipton.
Yup.
[inaudible].
And another one that's,
I find even much more compelling is the McNeely Kronen footprint,
the money McNeely Cron,
an expedition to the Aaron Valley in,
um,
in the Himalayas.
Um,
those suggested a creature that's actually probably much more akin to this
individual.
They exhibit a opposable or a divergent big toe.
In fact,
the McNeely Kronen particularly look just like an oversized chimpanzee with
short stout digits.
Hold this up.
So you feel like the Yeti,
my possibly if it's real,
my possibly would be a different animal rather different undisclosed,
right.
Probably probably one that's still our boreal that lives not up in the
snowfields but down in the,
uh,
sub tropical temperate valleys of the high,
mid Himalayas,
I guess you'd say like the Aaron Valley.
I mean,
McNeely,
Jeff McNeely and had had chron and we're,
we're,
um,
uh,
biologists who were conducting a two year biological survey,
the wildlife in that area,
wildlife and the flora.
And so when they,
when they woke up one morning and found the line of tracks that came up a very
steep slope through three feet of snow by Peterlee,
uh,
on a ridge leading to pass that they were just about to go over themselves,
made a detour,
meandered in amongst the brightly colored tents,
and then continued on over the past and they lost the trail in a Rhododendron
ticket.
But here were these chimpanzee,
like very large chimpanzee like footprints.
Do you,
um,
do you,
what,
what's your take on aliens or extra terrestrials?
Do you believe in Ufos?
Well,
uh,
you know,
and I always just chew that,
that term,
believe it doesn't matter if I believe or not,
but uh,
I,
I've not busied myself with the evidence.
I mean,
I saw a Ufo and unidentified flying object myself one time.
We are out looking at stars with,
you know,
a date.
Do you think big foot positive he was in that unit?
No,
I don't think so.
I never know until you're doing that,
you can imagine that what a mind fuck I would be then puts from another planet
and it just lands in,
likes to go for walks through the woods just like everybody else.
All I saw was it was a point of light,
you know,
when,
when we were kids,
we would sleep out on the sun deck and we'd count the satellites as they went
over and then a very particular kind of oblique orbits.
This thing was going north to south and which would have been fine except that
it executed to RightAngle.
Turns in succession.
I mean,
absolutely right.
Angle turns.
Just as sharp as if you put a square up there in the sky and,
and so I,
you know,
both our jaws dropped and did you see that?
Yeah.
Maybe there's the government because it's trying to throw you off this big foot
thing by making you look good
this more.
This was way before that.
This was back in college.
Maybe they have a time machine and they knew that you were going to be one of
the most prime it.
Well that's the thing about a big for research,
all these conspiracy theories.
If there's men in black out there,
you know,
harassing and intimidating these,
a big fit investigators,
either I'm a good,
a disseminator of disinformation or something.
Cause no one's ever shown up at my lab.
They don't bother you at all.
They haven't ever bothered me.
Yeah.
So the idea is you probably work for the CIA.
That's right.
You trained underground as hypnotic soothing voice.
You get around the stoners,
convinced them big foot exists,
leave little bread crumb trails,
you know,
you're the one with that bag of hairs.
I knew,
I know.
You're right.
That's it.
You're already a government agent.
Um,
the,
uh,
the possibility that Sasquatch predated humans in North America,
you brought that up.
What about the possibility that there some sort of a hybrid between humans and
Sasquatch?
Is that,
yeah,
I think it's very unlikely.
I mean,
I actually am aware of a couple of interesting stories from native American
sources that suggests that,
that,
uh,
that there was the possibility of,
of,
uh,
interview.
So
you feel like there's a Yeti,
which may or may not exist,
but if it does,
is it completely different species?
And then there's a Sasquatch.
There has been some talk about hybrids and including the Melba Catchum DNA
results,
which she reports to indicate some sort of a human and a primate unknown,
primate hybrid.
What do you,
how do you feel about the results of those?
Uh,
I don't hold those in,
in,
uh,
in very high regard.
I don't think that her results are that credible,
reliable,
and certainly her interpretation of the data is highly questionable.
Important to note that when you say a human Sasquatch hybrid,
what you're saying is that someone wasn't just lucky enough to discover a big
foot,
but they were also able to make love with the big,
yeah,
well we're talking about a long time ago and most likely they didn't even make
love with a big foot.
They made love with another thing and created big foot.
That's the idea.
That's,
that's her,
her thesis.
Yeah.
It's not being looked at with a rose colored glasses.
I mean even setting the,
in any suppose a data aside for a moment,
just to think about the,
the,
the feasibility of that scenario.
You have to have two populations that are at least close enough that they're
going to produce a viable and a fertile offspring.
And yet they're different enough that that offspring isn't subsumed into one or
the other of the parental population and,
and just,
you know,
diluted back into the gene pool.
They remain distinct and then the cross has have to be frequent enough.
The,
the,
you know,
the hook hooking up.
But,
uh,
yeah,
that there's,
that there's a substantial population than that that accrues and,
and that becomes Sasquatch and somehow gets from Europe to North America and
other parts of Asia and relinquishes all material culture and,
and other accoutrements of humanity.
And I mean,
it just,
it kind of a,
not only that,
how big must that thing have been?
People are our size and then there's Sasquatch,
which is even bigger.
This thing had to be even bigger than Sasquatch and had sex with a person made
something in the middle.
Right.
Does it work that way?
No,
it doesn't.
Yeah.
Science has not worked that way.
Do you know why it doesn't north that way?
Laggers.
Laggers are way bigger than tigers or lions,
Huh?
Yeah.
Cool.
I mean,
there,
there are,
yeah,
you can point to examples,
uh,
that they do.
Lions and tigers really aren't good biological species because they do,
when the,
when the opportunity presents,
they do cross and produce viable offspring,
but the viable offsprings are sterile or they not.
No.
Ligers my understanding is that laggers are not sterile real debt.
Yeah.
That you can,
you could breed,
you can in fact,
uh,
one of,
not Pocatello's but eastern Idaho,
his claim to fame was lagger town,
a couple of unscrupulous individuals that were,
were breeding and,
but not taking good care of them.
And all heck broke,
broke loose when they showed up outside of a school playground.
The laggers and oh well they found well beaten paths where they were getting out
on a regular basis before they were finally discovered.
And yeah,
it was,
it was pretty easy.
But that,
but that's an interesting,
interesting possible scenario.
Now I,
I started to mention that there's a couple of native American,
uh,
accounts that suggest,
you know,
there's always been this theme of abduction,
of,
of the,
uh,
you know,
the,
the Sasquatch abducting a human females.
But the only two that I'm aware of upon which I can base any,
you know,
any evaluation reported that there was a pregnancy,
there was a birth,
but the individual grew very rapidly,
very sickly and died and was stunted mentally and died before the,
you know,
reaching teen years suggesting it wasn't viable and probably wouldn't have been
fertile.
And this is an abduction.
Yeah.
Big Foot abducted.
A native American woman soldier brought her back and she had a baby that died.
Why did he bring her back?
Or She got away or whatever.
I knew she was annoying.
Yeah,
pretty big foot.
Thought it'd be really cool.
You know,
it's like a lot of hookups.
You build it up in your mind,
you know,
and then get together with her and the reality sets in.
Yeah.
Maybe she's anonymous stack with big foot.
I mean,
they sound like just so stories.
But you know,
we have some precedent Barouti gal because the Orangutan Lady,
a researcher,
she and her book reflections of Eden recounts a,
uh,
an instance where at a provisioning station,
her native,
um,
assistant was accosted by a young male,
uh,
orangutan who completed the deed.
And uh,
but he had been,
he was a hurry,
habituated or a repatriated,
I guess you'd say rehabilitate.
I'm not sure what the proper term is there one that had been confiscated and
then raised in and trained to return to the woods.
So it had some contact with humans previously,
but the,
but the point simply being is that that scenario is not completely out of the
question.
The question is what's the probability of there being a successful impregnation
between two different species now
I have never stopped.
Yeah.
It seems like if an orangutan had made love to a woman that I would have heard
of that by now.
And you would have to,
I don't think so.
There's that lady in Connecticut,
there was almost,
almost definitely sleeping with her chimp.
She was given it wine and Xanax and slept in the bed with her.
It was very jealous of her.
She's probably having sex with that thing.
But this is different from being on an expedition and having it rang a tank
barrel out of the forest and fuck you.
Yeah.
But I think it's probably pretty standard for rang tanks.
They're bigger,
were smaller.
They fucked us standard.
I think that's what they do when they're horny.
I don't think they really think about it.
There would be a blog dedicated to it.
Uh,
just not enough contact with people with cell phones that live.
This was a Pandora's box,
wasn't it?
Solo show is a Pandora's box.
Sorry,
I apologize for that.
The,
um,
the Jane Goodall quote,
boy,
when Jane Goodall came out and said that she believes 100%,
that Sasquatch is a real animal.
Did you go,
you must've been so pumped.
Well,
I followed up and,
uh,
and uh,
and saw and tried to see if she would read my book manuscript and possibly
endorse it,
which she did.
So the cover of my book boasts and endorsement from,
from Dr Goodall.
So have you spoken with her?
I have a couple of times.
What's her number one thing that she locks onto as far as both,
one of the things that really impressed her was the,
uh,
the,
accounts by native Americans that she's come to become acquainted with.
And the fact that they,
that they've had these encounters and that they,
uh,
that their oral traditions are so deep rooted about interactions and,
you know,
encounters with these creatures that they are,
they're part of the,
of the real landscape as well as,
you know,
as with so many animals,
the native American stories often have,
are,
are very metaphorical,
very like Aesop's fables,
a,
you know,
convey,
convey morals and so forth.
And so they are,
oftentimes the animals are anthropomorphic characteristics and or supernatural
characteristics.
But that doesn't change the fact that,
you know,
the clever,
um,
and,
and trickster coyote is based on a real species of animal.
So the wild man of the woods is probably the same.
What does Jane Goodall think of this footage?
You know what,
I haven't,
uh,
I haven't had that opportunity.
Our,
our conversations have always been very brief.
Unfortunately,
we haven't had the opportunity to sit down and speak at any great length,
but,
uh,
so I don't know what she would say about the,
about the footage.
What was your background before you became intoxicated with the bigfoot legend?
Right.
Well,
my,
my training is in anatomical sciences with an emphasis in physical anthropology.
So much of my day is spent,
uh,
teaching human gross anatomy,
full body dissection lab course to a health professions programs.
So,
you know,
I've been involved with the dissection of hundreds and hundreds of human bodies
know that machinery inside out.
Uh,
my research revolves around the evolution of human adaptations,
particularly those for walking on two legs and,
and more specifically the interpretation of,
of foot,
form and function as it relates to,
to bipedalism,
an Arborio quality and other other primates like the great apes and monkeys.
You're living in Washington state,
is that where you live?
Idaho,
state of Idaho,
Idaho State University and Woodsy out there,
right?
Well,
Pocatello is kind of a plunk there on the edge of the sagebrush step.
So we have to go a little ways to get to the Woodsy,
but there's lots of wild country.
We're just two hours away from the Tetons in Yellowstone national park.
And,
uh,
you went to his or just south of us.
So there's,
there's some root prime territory so you can go squatch and pretty close to your
house.
Sure.
Can you do,
do you do that?
I,
I've,
I've gone,
uh,
I go out with a,
a colleague,
John Mine Zinsky is a wildlife consultant and ethnobotanist and we've done a lot
of work in western Wyoming together.
And uh,
for a number of years we've spent at least a month at a time in the field
looking for trace evidence and trying to get DNA,
uh,
with various,
by various means.
Uh,
what'd you say that you spend more time dissecting?
Human bodies are hunting for big foot,
uh,
probably disecting human bodies.
Yeah.
But big foot,
it's really fun and certain bodies get boring after a while.
Right.
I never lose that.
Uh,
it has a certain,
a novelty to it every,
each and every year.
I mean,
everybody's a little different.
And,
and sharing that experience,
you know,
this is a real unique opportunity for students to have that very intimate
experience of dismantling that marvelous machine.
That's the human.
So it never,
it never really gets old for the record.
Just so for the show,
would you look at me and tell me exactly who you are and what your credentials
are?
Yeah.
My name is Jeff Meldrum.
I'm a professor of anatomy and anthropology at Idaho State University.
Uh,
I teach primarily anatomy and research,
uh,
the evolution of human bipedalism.
I hope you're right.
Aye.
I'm seriously
rooting for you.
There's not a lot of subjects that I really hope are true,
but big flip mad for me.
It has always been the one you FO's I'm pretty sure there's life out there.
Whether or not it's video,
excuse me,
whether or not it's visited us to him.
Well,
I'm,
I'm sort of iffy on that,
but big foot,
I'm open for man.
I'm God.
I want it to be,
well,
it's interesting.
There was a recently,
uh,
the,
the cover story of New Scientist magazine this year was a of one issue was what
are the top 10 questions that face human evolution that students of researchers
of human evolution today and number nine was our other hominins alive today.
So it's gaining some traction.
This,
this notion of relic hominids.
I've actually launched an online scholarly journal,
peer reviewed journal called the relic hominoid inquiry to provide a venue for
discussion and publication of,
of uh,
research on this topic.
And so it's,
it's making inroads a homo floresiensis that you're so interested that that was
really an interesting because yeah,
because here these,
these discovers kind of scratch their heads and admit to the report as well.
Yeah.
Actually the local people have been describing these little three foot tall,
hairy people that live up in the mountains and,
and uh,
even some of the European colonists of described encounters with them all along.
And that had been folklore for the longest time,
thought to be nothing but just stories until they found these belts.
What is it like 2006 or something like that?
Yeah.
It's just been a few,
a few years.
Crazy,
isn't it?
Little tiny.
Three foot tall nonhuman people.
Right.
I can levitate,
fly there,
just fly.
They don't levitate like Superman.
No.
Superman.
Love it.
They walk through the trees,
the RUC way through the tree.
They become one with the tree from,
from what I read.
The little people can fly.
Where are the little people suppose?
I mean there's also the Orang Pendek right,
right.
Whereas the thing supposed to live
comes from Malaysia.
So,
uh,
Flores is a little island of Indonesia,
but there are reports of these small hominids all throughout Southeast Asia.
Recent reports,
right?
Oh yes.
Contemporary reports.
Absolutely.
As well as the native trees.
There's still alive.
Yeah.
Little tiny signs.
A very smart apparently well from people and very smart.
Yeah.
Fascinating stuff.
Nothing.
Dr Male Gym.
Seriously,
thank you so much and thank you for all this work because if it wasn't for a guy
like you,
an actual intellectual smart dude who is obsessed with big foot as well,
it would be so sketchy because you're getting this information from all these
various sources.
Some of them highly doped up.
You know,
it's,
it's hard.
It's hard to celebrate the wheat from the shaft.
No,
he's saying the wheat from the chaff,
from the chat.
It's hard.
I don't think it's shaft.
It's,
it's hard.
You know,
when you're a person like myself who is not an educated in anthropology to
dissect this stuff.
And,
uh,
if it wasn't for people like you out there,
I think the overall picture would be far muddier.
So thank you,
sir.
I really,
really appreciate it.
A pleasure and an honor having you on.
Really appreciate that.
Sure.